[Musik]
>> MURAT: Dam-da-dam-da-daa!
Dam-da-dam-da-daa!
Oh, die Wurst!
Sally! Wasser!
Sally!
>> SALLY: Murat!
>> MURAT: Feuer!
Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
>> SALLY: Murat, ernsthaft?!
>> MURAT: So.
Herzlich willkommen zu
Murats 5 Minuten oder auch länger.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein 5-Minuten-Rezept ist.
Definitiv nicht.
Weil ich bin heute alleine.
Ich habe natürlich einen Gast bei mir,
wie immer.
Ich koche immer gerne mit einem Gast.
Ich habe einen Gast, der hat einen weiten Weg noch vor sich.
Ihr kennt den Gast wahrscheinlich alle.
Und zwar ist es meine Tochter
Samira.
>> ELA: Darf ich mitmachen?
>> MURAT: So.
Meine Tochter Samira
direkt den weiten Weg aus dem Wohnzimmer.
Und meine Tochter Ela.
So. Jetzt wird es richtig stressig!
Mein Gott!
Ich habe hier so viele Zutaten
und habe auch noch zwei Kinder.
Ach, ich bin schon voll aus der Puste.
Okay.
Wir machen eine coole...
>> ELA: Papa?
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> ELA: Papa? Kann ich das
die Paprika anbeißen?
>> MURAT: Nein, darfst du nicht.
So.
Auf jeden Fall...
Ich bin jetzt schon völlig durcheinander.
Schön, dass du da bist,
schön, dass du da bist
und ihr mich unterstützt dabei, okay?
Geht mir nicht auf den Keks,
weil ich
komme alleine schon nicht klar.
Okay.
Auf jeden Fall Folgendes:
Wir fangen an mit einer Nudelreispfanne
– nee, ich habe keinen Nudelreis.
Ich meine, mit Fleisch, Reis-
>> ELA: Papa!
>> MURAT: Gemüse-Pfanne.
Danke, Schatz.
So. Den brauche ich nicht.
So.
Aber fangen wir an.
Also...
>> ELA: Papa, du sollst den Apfel essen!
>> MURAT: Ja, esse ich, Schatzi.
So. Wir fangen an mit den Zutaten.
Und bei den Zutaten ist es so:
Ich koche jetzt für eine zehnköpfige Familie,
also für das ganze Team.
Es ist Freitag jetzt bei mir.
Vielleicht ist bei euch jetzt auch gerade Freitag.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und wir kochen für das ganze Team.
Die Kinder sind bei mir. Die helfen mir jetzt.
Und ja,
fangen wir an, okay?
Fangen wir mit den Zutaten an?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also haben wir hier
Olivenöl,
Zwiebeln,
Knoblauch,
Zucchini,
zwei Paprikas.
Dann habe ich hier
>> MURAT & ELA: Champignons.
>> MURAT: Gemüsebrühe,
Sahne.
Dann brauche ich ein bisschen Stärke
>> ELA: Stärke.
>> MURAT: zum Soßeandicken nachher.
Ein bisschen Petersilie.
Das ist eine glatte Petersilie.
>> ELA: Ich hatte auch schon mal Petersilie gegessen.
>> MURAT: Gut, Samira
– Ela.
Dann habe ich hier Frühlingszwiebeln.
Dann habe ich hier natürlich
Fleisch.
>> SAMIRA: Da.
>> ELA: Das nicht.
>> MURAT: Und dann habe ich hier Reis
und Salz.
So. Die ganz genauen Mengen
könnt ihr im Blog oder auf der App sehen.
Da gebt ihr einfach an, für wie viele Personen,
und dann gibt es eine automatische Umrechnungstabelle.
Also ganz, ganz easy.
Guckt die Zutaten noch mal in richtigen Mengen
auf dem Blog oder auf der App an.
Die ist übrigens kostenlos.
So.
>> ELA: Papa?
>> MURAT: Ja, Ela?
>> ELA: Ist das dein Ernst?
>> MURAT: Ja, Ela, das ist mein Ernst.
So. Okay.
Dann fangen wir an.
Als Allerallererstes fangen wir an mit dem Reis.
Und zwar ist es hier ein Naturkornreis.
Das ist ein natürlicher Reis,
nicht zu verwechseln mit dem anderen Reis,
der von den Feldern kommt.
Diesen Reis hier machen wir zuallererst.
Und beim Reis steht immer hinten auf der Verpackung drauf,
– weil beim Reis ist es immer unterschiedlich –
wie viel Menge zum Reis
– wie viel?
Was für ein Verhältnis. Genau.
Was für ein Verhältnis.
Was ist das Verhältnis zwischen dir und mir?
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Ähm.
>> MURAT: Du bist meine Tochter, ich bin dein Papa.
So.
Und hier ist es einfach unterschiedlich.
Das heißt, guckt auf die Packungsbeilage.
So. Jetzt tun wir hier den Reis
gerade in das Wasser rein.
Das habe ich schon reingemacht.
Zack!
So.
Dann noch das Salz.
Zack!
Siehst du das, Samira?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, ich sehe es.
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn, oder?
Und schön kochen lassen.
Und der Reis saugt jetzt das ganze Wasser auf.
Wusstest du das?
Ja, wie so ein Schwamm.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Okay.
>> ELA: Weil das ist mehr Wasser als da der Reis.
>> MURAT: Genau.
So.
>> SAMIRA: Das kann man so sagen.
Kann man so sagen.
>> MURAT: So.
Okay.
>> SAMIRA: Papa, sagst du das gleich mit dem...
So...
Ja...
>> MURAT: Okay, alles klar.
Zuallererst nehmen wir dieses Hüftsteak.
Das ist übrigens ein Bio-Hüftsteak,
Biofleisch.
Das ist auch einvakuumiert.
Richtig toll!
Sieht gigantisch aus!
Und das schneiden wir jetzt in Scheiben.
Weil wir tun zuerst Folgendes machen:
Wir tun das Fleisch anbraten,
nur ganz, ganz kurz ganz scharf anbraten.
Und dann tun wir es auf die Seite legen.
Weil das Wichtige ist beim Fleisch:
Nicht zu sehr anbraten.
Sonst wird es nämlich wie Gummi.
Und das machen wir jetzt so am Anfang.
Mmh!
So.
Das ist jetzt ein Hüftsteak.
Samira, solang ich jetzt das in Scheiben schneide,
machst du die einfachen Sachen, okay?
>> SAMIRA: Warum?
>> MURAT: Weil du die Schlauste hier drin bist.
Deswegen machst du die einfacheren Sachen.
>> SAMIRA: Aber das macht doch gar keinen Sinn.
Weil dann müsste ich doch die Dinge machen
und du das andere.
>> MURAT: Hat sie recht?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Während ich das mache, Schatz,
tust du Folgendes:
Einfach die Zwiebeln schälen
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: und dann zur Hälfte schneiden, okay?
>> ELA: Dann will ich das tun.
>> SALLY: Pass auf beim Schneiden.
>> MURAT: Beim Fleisch ist ganz, ganz wichtig
– es ist ein ganz normales Hüftsteak,
Bioqualität.
Man sieht es ganz, ganz extrem.
Josh, komm mal ganz kurz her.
Lass mal kurz die Maserung sehen.
Siehst du diese Maserung?
Richtig genial!
Beim Fleisch ist auch ganz, ganz wichtig:
Wenn ihr manchmal
– weil viele machen den einen Fehler.
Die holen vielleicht Fleisch aus dem Kühlschrank
oder aus der Gefriertruhe,
tun es ganz kurz auftauen und sofort in die Pfanne.
Das ist falsch!
Ihr müsst wirklich gucken,
dass Fleisch immer auf Zimmertemperatur angebraten wird.
Weil dann bleibt es so richtig schön zart.
Ansonsten, kommt das kalte Fleisch
mit der heißen Pfanne zusammen,
zieht sich es zusammen und es wird richtig zäh.
Okay, Schatzi?
Genau, einfach die Zwiebeln auseinander.
Und ich tu jetzt hier schöne Streifen schneiden.
Und das Fleisch nicht zu dünn.
>> ELA: Ich bin brav.
>> MURAT: Dann bleibt es auch schön saftig nachher.
>> ELA: Samira ist kreativ.
>> SAMIRA: Pst, pst, pst!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Du musst schneller werden, Samira.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, ich schäle die gerade.
>> MURAT: Wie die Chinesen ganz schnell.
>> SAMIRA: Einfach durch die Mitte?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Nicht mehr?
>> MURAT: Ja, nur durch die Mitte, Schatz.
Das reicht schon.
Weil ich gebe dir nachher gleich was.
Da musst du beim Zwiebelnschälen nachher nicht weinen.
>> SAMIRA: Gesehen?
>> MURAT: Da gibt es einen coolen Trick.
Den zeige ich dir gleich.
Okay?
>> ELA: Und, und...
>> MURAT: Ela, du kannst nicht
alle Äpfel und Birnen anbeißen!
>> SAMIRA: Das ist eine Banane!
>> MURAT: Aha!
>> ELA: Ich esse doch nicht alles.
Ich esse nur ein paar.
>> MURAT: So.
Jetzt habe ich das Fleisch schon mal geschnitten.
Jetzt gibt es einen coolen Trick.
Josh, das zeige ich dir mal ganz kurz.
Komm mal kurz näher.
So.
Wichtig ist beim Fleischanbraten immer,
dass man die richtige Temperatur erwischt.
Das heißt: Ist die Pfanne heiß genug?
Wie schnell darf man eine Pfanne erhitzen?
Und allem Drum und Dran.
Oftmals gibt es ja auch solche Pfannen,
die so einen roten Punkt in der Mitte haben,
und erst, wenn der rote Punkt leuchtet,
dann ist es die richtige Temperatur,
um das Fleisch reinzuwerfen.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz:
Ich mache das in so einer Gusspfanne.
Und zwar gehe ich hier drauf,
mache die Vollfläche an,
auch ein ganz cooles Gadget.
So.
Und jetzt stelle ich auf Pfanne,
Stufe 5.
Genau.
Jetzt habe ich die Pfanne drauf gemacht.
Und jetzt piepst gerade der Herd und sagt zu mir:
"Hey, ich habe die perfekte Temperatur.
Und jetzt wirf das Fleisch rein."
Guck mal. Jetzt zeige ich dir mal was ganz Cooles, Samira.
Und zwar Zwiebeln schneiden ohne,
dass du weinen musst.
Und hier nehmen wir den Knoblauch auch noch gleich.
Den tun wir auch gleich rein.
[Musik]
So.
Das machst du jetzt einfach in den Speedwing rein.
Und jetzt, ohne dass du jetzt weinen musst.
Komm, ich zeige dir das Ganze.
Okay?
Siehst du das?
Komm, zieh mal.
Jawoll!
Genau.
So.
Papa macht jetzt mal, kurz zweimal.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, sieben, acht.
So.
Siehst du?
Perfekt zerkleinert. Siehst du das?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: So. Ohne zu weinen.
So.
Jetzt hat die Pfanne gerade gepiepst.
Jetzt nehmen wir das Fleisch
und tun es gerade in der Pfanne kurz anbraten.
Oh!
>> JOSH: Du musst den Abzug anmachen.
>> MURAT: Sally, geh weg!
Ela, geh weg.
>> SAMIRA: Ela, geh weg!
>> MURAT: Geh weg.
So. Jetzt machen wir das Fleisch rein.
So.
Auf jeden Fall das Fleisch
von beiden Seiten anbraten.
Von mir aus immer nur die Hälfte rein
und dann die nächste Hälfte anbraten.
Und das Fleisch, wie meine Frau sagt, gut behandeln.
Weil das ist Biofleisch.
Ihr müsst das nicht massieren,
aber...
>> ELA: Ich kann Bilder an die Wand machen.
>> MURAT: So.
[Musik]
Jetzt tun wir das wieder runterschalten.
>> SAMIRA: Ich mache das noch ein bisschen.
>> MURAT: So.
Perfekt! Das reicht schon.
Jetzt machen wir noch Folgendes, Schatz.
Ich zeige euch das auch mal ganz kurz.
Genau.
Samira, hier den Strunk wegschneiden
und hinten auch ein bisschen.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Perfekt!
Und jetzt in der Mitte.
>> SAMIRA: Da?
>> MURAT: Einmal durch die Mitte durch. Genau.
Perfekt!
Und jetzt zeige ich dir mal einen neuen Trick.
Weil
es kommt beim Geschmack
natürlich auch extrem auf die Konsistenz an.
Jetzt machen wir mal was richtig Cooles.
Guck mal, hier machst du das drauf.
So.
Okay? Pass auf.
Siehst du das?
So.
Perfekt!
>> SAMIRA: Bitte sehr.
>> MURAT: Das nächste. Genau.
Wieder drauf.
Siehst du das?
Und jetzt wieder.
>> MURAT: Jetzt haben wir nämlich
so richtig coole Gemüsespaghetti.
>> SAMIRA: Aha.
>> MURAT: Das schmeckt auch ganz anders,
obwohl es eigentlich das Gleiche ist,
als wenn du es in Scheiben essen würdest.
Siehst du das?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: So.
Machst du das auch mal?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: So.
So. Jetzt probiere es mal selber.
Genau.
Und jetzt schön fest draufdrücken.
Und jetzt einfach...
Genau.
Perfekt!
Jetzt lass mal kurz Papa was machen.
Guck mal, hier kannst du nämlich die Dicke noch einstellen,
wie dick du es haben möchtest.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Zack!
Pass mal auf, was der Papa jetzt kurz macht.
Jetzt nimmt er es schon mal
und tut das schon mal in die Pfanne reingeben.
Jawoll!
So.
>> SAMIRA: Hier sind noch welche.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und wieder drauf.
So.
Jetzt machst du noch den Rest hier auch noch fertig.
Genau.
Schön draufdrücken. Genau.
Von oben nach. Genau.
Perfekt!
So.
Das Coole ist, die Kinder können sich dabei nicht schneiden.
Also richtig cool auch für Kids.
Und einfach hier oben rausziehen,
drauf.
So. Richtig coole Gemüsenudeln, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
Das macht dann auch irgendwie mehr Spaß, die zu essen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
Während Samira das macht,
nehme ich hier gerade die Paprika.
Da hole ich den Strunk raus
Ja?
Habt ihr gesehen?
Wahnsinn!
So.
Und jetzt schneide ich die Paprika.
So. Da nehmen wir auch wieder die Streifen.
Die machen wir auch rein.
So.
Perfekt, Schatz!
>> SAMIRA: Eine leckere Gemüsepfanne.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt tust du mir noch einen Gefallen.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Weißt du, was du auch noch machst?
>> SAMIRA: Häckseln?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und zwar Folgendes.
Jetzt tun wir die Zwiebeln auch noch mit rein.
Ich zeige dir das kurz.
Die Zwiebeln hauen wir jetzt auch noch mit rein.
>> SAMIRA: Oh!
Wie so ein Auge.
>> MURAT: So.
Jetzt tust du mir noch einen Gefallen, Samira.
Genial!
So.
Pass mal auf.
Die Zwiebeln tust du jetzt auch klein schneiden, Schatz,
aber, guck mal, nur so.
So.
Auch mit rein.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, das kann ich.
>> MURAT: Auch mit rein. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und so reinschneiden
und dann lässt du es noch mal laufen, okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SAMIRA: Achtung, Papa.
>> MURAT: In der Zwischenzeit räume ich auf.
[Musik]
So. Samira, jetzt nimmst du mal noch den hier.
Jetzt zeige ich dir noch mal kurz was.
Erst macht der Papa kurz sauber.
Jetzt tust du die Champignons
– die Champignons darfst du jetzt nicht zerhäckseln, okay?
Die will ich schön bissfest haben.
Jetzt machst du es immer so:
Du nimmst immer die Hälfte,
nimmst hier komplett die Hälfte.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und jetzt weißt du, was passiert.
>> ELA: Papa?
>> MURAT: Das da drauf. Genau.
>> SAMIRA: Das muss man noch abmachen.
>> ELA: Das riecht nach Pommes!
>> MURAT: Das ist kein Pommes, Schatz.
Das ist Fleisch.
>> ELA: Aber es riecht nach Pommes.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Du musst den Deckel wegmachen, Schatzi.
So.
So. Jetzt.
>> SAMIRA: Upsi.
>> MURAT: Darf ich kurz?
Siehst du das?
Hier die Hälfte.
>> SAMIRA: Du musst erst den Stiel abmachen.
>> MURAT: Nee, lass den Stiel dran.
Der schmeckt am besten.
So. Das letzte jetzt noch.
Und, damit alles durch ist,
machst du das hier rein.
So.
Es ist alles in Scheiben geschnitten jetzt.
Siehst du das?
Und jetzt einfach hierein.
Zack!
Siehst du das?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn!
So.
So rein.
Das machen wir auch alles rein.
Jawoll!
Oh, guck mal! Richtig cool!
>> SAMIRA: Ich
mache das,
die Petersilie jetzt klein
und mache es dann in den
>> MURAT: Speedwing rein.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau. Auf die Finger aufpassen.
Genau.
Schneide es erst und dann tu es rein, Schatzi.
>> SAMIRA: Okay.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Keine Angst.
Genau. Keine Angst.
Perfekt!
So.
Genau.
Hm.
Und die Petersilie, die kommt immer ganz zum Schluss rein.
Weil das bringt noch mal dieses coole Aroma
von einer Petersilie.
Wichtig ist hier:
Benutzt wirklich glatte Petersilie.
Krause Petersilie schmeckt ganz, ganz anders.
So.
Während das jetzt hier alles
so ein bisschen vor sich her köchelt.
So.
Gerade noch ein bisschen vorköcheln lassen.
Das ist, weil du ein bisschen zu viel reingemacht hast, Schatzi.
Ganz fest.
Ja.
So.
Ja, der Papa hat schon Schwung, he?
Noch mal.
Ups.
Ein bisschen tun wir noch in die Pfanne rein
und, wenn was übrig bleibt von der Petersilie,
tun wir sie einfach einfrieren, okay?
Wir haben zwei, drei Veganer bei uns.
Deswegen werde ich Folgendes machen:
Ich werde nachher ein bisschen rausmachen
für die Veganer
und später erst das Fleisch dazu,
dass die Veganer es komplett vegan haben.
Und ich mache das nachher mit Fleisch natürlich.
>> SAMIRA: Aber, Papa,
du hast doch schon das Fleisch in der Pfanne angebraten.
>> MURAT: Ja, das wissen aber nur du und ich.
Oder?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, und die, die das Video schneiden.
>> MURAT: Ja, und die Veganer wissen es nicht.
Weil die sind in der Bildbearbeitung.
Ja, mh.
So.
Du brauchst keine Angst haben. Da passiert nichts.
>> SAMIRA: Mh.
>> MURAT: So.
Schön angebraten.
Jetzt tun wir das ein bisschen
– die Temperatur noch ein bisschen hochschalten.
So.
Das köchelt auch richtig schön.
Jetzt tun wir es ein bisschen ablöschen
mit der Gemüsebrühe.
Und zwar habe ich hier Gemüsebrühe,
da hat die Sally ja auch schon ein Rezept drüber gemacht.
Das findet ihr hier
in der Beschreibung.
Ihr könnt auch einen ganz normalen Gemüsewürfel nehmen.
Schön ablöschen ein bisschen.
Jawoll!
Oh!
Und jetzt einfach ein bisschen reduzieren lassen.
Das heißt, reduzieren heißt einfach
das Wasser ein bisschen aufkochen lassen.
So.
>> SAMIRA: Und Papa,
was ist jetzt mit der Sahne und mit der Stärke?
>> MURAT: Die Sahne machen wir jetzt auch rein, Schatz.
Und die Stärke machen wir nur rein,
wenn es nachher zu dünnflüssig ist.
Weißt du, das bindet dann die Soße.
Dann wird es ein bisschen
wie Kleister.
So.
>> JOSH: Oh, warte.
>> MURAT: Ah, jetzt habe ich einen Fehler gemacht.
Jetzt haben wir einen Fehler gemacht, Schatzi.
>> SAMIRA: Du.
>> MURAT: Jetzt habe ich Sahne reingemacht.
Jetzt können es die Veganer gar nicht mehr essen.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, dann aber...
Was machen wir jetzt für die Veganer?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, das frage ich mich auch gerade.
>> MURAT: Ja, das war jetzt nicht so gut, gell?
Meinst du, das fällt jemandem auf, dass da Milch drin ist?
>> SAMIRA: Natürlich!
Es ist etwas Weißes.
Und was ist ein weißes Getränk,
>> MURAT: Milch.
>> SAMIRA: das keine Milch ist?
>> MURAT: Weißt du, was wir machen?
Wir tun jetzt einfach kurz solang aufräumen, okay?
Oh!
[Musik]
Ah, bin ich dir ins Bild reingelaufen?
So.
Jetzt lassen wir es gerade ein bisschen köcheln
und jetzt können wir es auch würzen.
Ganz, ganz wichtig:
Ich habe ja auch vorhin gesagt,
das Fleisch nicht vorher würzen.
Mmh.
Mmh!
Perfekt!
Tu mir einen Gefallen, Schatz.
Salz.
Zuerst ein bisschen Salz.
Genau.
Da kannst du ruhig ein bisschen mehr machen.
Genau. Schön grob eingestellt.
Perfekt!
Komm, noch ein bisschen.
So.
Jetzt nimmst du ein bisschen Pfeffer,
schwarzen Pfeffer.
Ich finde es immer cool,
wenn man so ein Pfeffergemisch macht.
Das heißt, ich mag grünen Pfeffer sehr, sehr gerne
oder roten Pfeffer auch
und so einen Mix.
Ich habe da jetzt nur schwarzen Pfeffer genommen.
Also, wenn ihr daheim verschiedene Pfeffersorten habt,
nehmt das ruhig.
>> SAMIRA: Das reicht, oder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und jetzt kommt was ganz Besonderes.
Ich liebe das einfach!
>> SAMIRA: Koriander.
>> MURAT: Das ist Koriander.
Koriander mit Rindfleisch zusammen
ist wirklich der absolute Hammer!
Und jetzt habe ich noch
– jetzt kann man das natürlich ein bisschen reduzieren,
das heißt, ein bisschen mehr Hitze geben,
dass die Flüssigkeit ein bisschen weggeht.
Oder man macht es ein bisschen schneller.
Man nimmt einfach ein bisschen Stärke, Schatzi.
Gibst du mir ein bisschen Stärke?
>> SAMIRA: Wir machen erst mal die Hälfte rein, oder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
Ah, es ist mir reingerutscht.
Kein Problem. Kein Problem.
So.
Merkst du das?
Das wird jetzt die Soße ein bisschen binden.
Aber ein bisschen Flüssigkeit ist schon in Ordnung.
So.
So. Jetzt machen wir noch das Fleisch rein.
Ich mache das Fleisch rein, oder, Schatz?
>> SALLY: Nee, einfach nicht mehr kochen lassen.
>> MURAT: Nicht mehr kochen lassen?
>> SALLY: Also lege das Fleisch erst rein,
wenn wir gleich essen.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay. Erst reinlegen...
Also...
Einen kleinen Tipp von mir natürlich:
Das Fleisch erst ganz zum Schluss.
Aber nicht mehr kochen lassen,
sondern einfach nur noch drauf legen
mit der Petersilie.
Aber jetzt lassen wir es noch ein bisschen reduzieren.
So.
Mmh!
Gibst du mir mal eine Gabel, Schatz?
Dann probieren wir mal.
Boah, Hammer!
Noch ein bisschen Salz.
Ein bisschen Pfeffer.
Oh! Und ein bisschen Koriander.
Koriander könnt ihr gar nicht zu viel reinmachen.
Also zu viel Koriander ist eigentlich gar nicht möglich.
Das ist nicht so ein Gewürz, was so richtig extrem ist.
Es geht weder in die Schärfe noch ins Salzige mit rein.
Es gibt dem Essen einfach noch mal das besondere Etwas.
Perfekt!
Boah! Ich liebe das einfach!
So.
Was machen wir den Veganern?
Haben wir noch Brezeln da?
Haben wir noch Brezeln da für die Veganer?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, dort.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
Okay.
Oh!
Guck mal. Der Reis ist auch schon fertig.
Siehst du das, Schatz?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Richtig cool, oder?
Reis machen ist ganz einfach.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: So.
Machen wir hier auch den Deckel zu.
So.
Jetzt machen wir Folgendes:
Jetzt nehmen wir es vom Herd.
Zack!
>> SAMIRA: Da war gerade ein Riesending.
>> MURAT: So, Schatz.
Jetzt tun wir noch hier
über das Fleisch auch noch ein bisschen Salz.
So. Jetzt geben wir das Fleisch mit rein
mit dem ganzen Bratensud.
Perfekt!
>> SAMIRA: Was ist Bratensud?
>> MURAT: Das ist der Saft vom Fleisch.
Boah! Jetzt sollten wir eigentlich kurz Sarah rufen, oder?
Da könnte die Sarah aber ein richtig cooles Bild machen.
So.
>> SAMIRA: Ich rufe sie.
>> MURAT: Genau. Hol du mal die Sarah.
So. Jetzt nehmen wir am Schluss
noch ein bisschen die Petersilie.
Nicht übertreiben.
So. Und wenn ihre jetzt noch
– wie gesagt, ich habe noch ziemlich viel Petersilie übrig.
Wir haben ein bisschen zu viel genommen.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Petersilie kann man einfach einfrieren.
Das alles einfach in einen Turnbeutel rein
– in einen
Gefrierbeutel rein
und dann einfach in den Kühlschrank geben.
So.
Jetzt suche ich gerade mein Handy,
weil ich würde das gern fotografieren.
Das sieht ja wahnsinnig aus!
Guck mal, Josh.
Josh, Josh...
Au, au, au.
Jetzt komm mal her. Komm mal hinter die Kamera.
Schau dir mal an, was dein Mann hergerichtet hat
– angerichtet hat.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn, oder?
Sarah, komm mal du mit der Kamera kurz her.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Habt ihr das schon mal gesehen?
>> SARAH: Nee.
>> MURAT: Guck mal das an.
Guck mal. Jetzt kommen plötzlich alle!
Guck mal.
Das ist also...
Habt ihr gedacht, das Jesuskind wäre hier?
Guck mal hier.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
Mama?
>> ELA: Njam, njam.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SARAH: Njam, njam.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, die Ela hat gesagt,
>> SALLY: Können wir jetzt essen?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe so Hunger.
>> SAMIRA: ihr Bauch
>> SARAH: Nee, noch nicht.
>> SAMIRA: will Chicken Nuggets.
>> ELA: Nein, mein Rücken hat gesagt,
>> SARAH: Der Rücken?
>> ELA: ich will Chicken Nuggets.
>> SALLY: Dein Rücken?
>> MURAT: Dein Rücken hat gesagt,
du willst Chicken McNuggets?
>> ELA: Nein, mein Rülpsen!
>> MURAT: Dein Rülpsen hat gesagt,
du willst Chicken McNuggets? Okay.
Auf jeden Fall sieht das hammermäßig aus.
Natürlich jetzt zusammen mit Reis
zusammen an-
Wie nennt sich das?
>> ELA: Ich habe es gehört!
>> SARAH: Anrichten. >> SAMIRA: Anbraten!
>> MURAT: Anrichten. Genau, anrichten.
So, ihr Schlaumeier.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß, was sie meinte!
Ihr Magen hat geknurrt.
>> MURAT: Ach so, ihr Magen hat geknurrt. Okay.
>> SALLY: Deswegen sagt sie Rülpsen.
>> MURAT: Kann mir jemand kurz mein Handy bringen?
Das sieht doch der Wahnsinn aus!
Ich bin der volle...
>> SARAH: Keine Handyfotos. Du kriegst meine.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Also das ist ja wirklich...
Ich komme mir vor wie so ein Künstler.
Krass!
[Musik]
So. Jetzt sind wir fertig.
Und jetzt darf die Samira mal probieren.
Jetzt haben wir ein bisschen viel Reis,
muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Aber wir sind auch zehn Personen momentan.
>> SAMIRA: Elf.
>> MURAT: Elf?
Okay.
So. Jetzt gucken wir, ob ich es wie Mama hinkriege.
So.
Und dann machen wir das da drauf.
Du bist mehr so
– o mein Gott! Ich kann es nicht anrichten wie Mama.
>> ELA: Ich liebe mehr Fleisch.
>> SAMIRA: Du brauchst auch einen Schöpflöffel.
>> MURAT: Ah ja, stimmt. Ja.
Egal, egal.
Komm, komm. Das reicht schon, Schatz.
Probiere es einfach jetzt mal aus.
Und jetzt sagst du, wie es schmeckt, und bist ehrlich.
>> ELA: Ich will auch mal!
>> MURAT: Du darfst auch.
Aber erst darf mal deine Schwester probieren, okay?
Danach darfst du.
>> SAMIRA: Ich probiere mal zuerst den Reis.
>> MURAT: Du kannst ruhig ehrlich sein, wenn was fehlt.
Wie schmeckt der Reis?
>> SAMIRA: Gut.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SAMIRA: Wie Naturreis.
Ehrlich?
Und dir?
>> SAMIRA: Gut.
>> MURAT: Hat es auch geschmeckt?
Ganz ehrlich jetzt?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Auf jeden Fall sieht es auch richtig cool aus.
Und ich hoffe, es schmeckt auch allen.
Saumäßig schnell gemacht.
Ich muss
– das gefällt mir richtig cool, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber
– jetzt nicht böse sein oder so, falsch verstehen –
der Reis, ich habe zum ersten Mal Reis gemacht,
also richtig alleine gemacht und es hat funktioniert.
Voll einfach, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und das Fleisch schmeckt auch super?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Nicht so viel, Ela. Langsam essen.
Okay. Auf jeden Fall den Kids schmeckt es.
Coole Geschichte.
Ich hoffe, das Rezept hat euch gefreut.
Schaut in der App vorbei.
Abonniert den Kanal natürlich.
In der App könnt ihr alles umrechnen.
Da stehen die ganzen Mengenangaben drauf.
Das rechnet von alleine um.
Und macht das einfach.
Insgesamt hat das, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
eine halbe Stunde gedauert,
Maximum eine halbe Stunde.
Das meist ist das Schnippeln,
aber das geht auch ziemlich leicht mit dem Speedwing.
Und das war jetzt in Ordnung, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Macht's gut! Macht's besser!
>> ELA: Das schmeckt halt echt wie Naturreis.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Macht's gut! Macht's besser!
>> SAMIRA: Ja, weil das Naturreis ist.
>> MURAT: Euer Murat, Samira und Ela.
Tschüss!
>> ELA: Und das schmeckt wie Noob
und das schmeckt wie Pro-Fleisch.
>> MURAT: Darf ich auch mal?
>> ELA: Gut?
>> MURAT: Mmh! Voll zart, eh!
Voll der Hammer!
Mmh!
Mh.
Ich nehme eine eigene, okay?
Mmh!
Also alle zusammen essen.
Kommt. Wir gehen an den Tisch.
Alle an den Tisch. Kommt.
>> ELA: Ich...
[Musik]